>> MR. PRESIDENT, THE
PROSECUTION'S CLOSING IN.
I'M AFRAID IT MIGHT BE OVER.
>> OH, IT'S NOT OVER.
NOT BY A LONG SHOT.
WE'LL BEAT THIS.
OR MY NAME ISN'T DARIUS TRUMP.
>> FROM THE PRODUCERS OF --
"EMPIRE,"
IT'S "THEM TRUMPS."
THE FIRST SHOW TO ASK THE
QUESTION, WHAT IF DONALD TRUMP
WAS BLACK?
DARIUS TRUMP, HIS WIFE MALIKA,
DARIUS JR., AND LAVANKA.
TOGETHER THEY ARE "THEM TRUMPS."
>> SIR, THEY KNOW EVERYTHING.
THEY KNOW ABOUT RUSSIA.
THEY KNOW YOU USED CAMPAIGN
MONEY TO COVER UP AN AFFAIR WITH
MAGIC CITY STRIPPER
CINNAMON MERCEDES.
AND THEY KNOW ABOUT THE PYRAMID
SCHEME YOU HAVE BEEN RUNNING
THROUGH YOUR COMPANY,
DARIUS TRUMP COUNTRY HAMS.
>> MM-MM.
>> DAD, THE MEDIA HAS BEEN OUT
FOR YOU SINCE DAY ONE AND YOU
PROVED THEM ALL WRONG.
>> THAT'S RIGHT, NOBODY EVER
THOUGHT YOU WOULD GET THIS FAR.
THE BANKRUPTCIES, YOUR BABY
MAMA.
BUT HERE YOU ARE ON TOP.
>> YEAH.
MAYBE I DONE SOME DIRTY THINGS.
I'M MAKING AMERICA GREAT AGAIN.
AND WHAT THESE FEDS DON'T
REALIZE IS THAT I'M THE
PRESIDENT!
THE MOST POWERFUL MAN IN THE
MOST RESPECTED OFFICE IN THE
WORLD.
THEY CAN'T LIKE ME.
AND EVEN THOUGH I MAY BE
BLACK --
>> FREEZE, TRUMP, YOU'RE UNDER
ARREST!
>> YEAH, THAT SOUNDS ABOUT
RIGHT.
>> ON THE NEXT "THEM TRUMPS."
>> ALL HAIL THE CHIEF.
>> DAD, YOU'RE BACK.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
THERE'S ONLY ONE ROOM IN
AMERICA.
YOU CAN'T PROSECUTE A SITTING
PRESIDENT.
IT'S CALLED CHECKS AND BALANCES
BABY, AND EVEN THOUGH I'M
BLACK --
>> YOU'VE BEEN IMPEACHED.
>> YEAH, I WAS WAITING ON THAT.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]